ANTETOKOUNMPO AND HIS ABILITY TO
PLAY SO MANY MINUTES AND THEY'LL
LOOK TO BOUNCE BACK ON THURSDAY
IN GAME TWO.
AND CHRIS PAUL WITH HIS FIRST
FINALS GAME, ONE HE WILL NOT
SOON FORGET.
HE'S WITH MALIKA.
>> Malika: CHRIS, WHAT FLIPPED
FOR YOU IN THE SECOND HALF?
>> CHANGING THE GAME.
I SAW THE SHOTS THEY WAS GIVING
ME AND I WAS JUST MISSING THEM,
SO, I KEPT TRYING TO BE
AGGRESSIVE.
MY GUYS GOT GOING AND CAM PAYNE
AND ALL THE COACHES HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT US PLAYING WITH
PACE.
I'M THE OLD HEAD THAT LIKE TO
SLOW IT DOWN SOMETIMES, BUT IN
THIS SERIES WE GOT TO PLAY WITH
PACE.
>> Malika: DEANDRE AYTON AND
DEVIN BOOKER HAVE BOTH TALKED
ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU MEAN TO THEM.
BUT WATCHING THEM, THE
CONNECTION GUYS HAD ON THE
COURT, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO
YOU?
>> IT'S TRUST.
IT'S TRUST.
WE'VE BEEN BUILDING IT ALL
SEASON LONG.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP PLAYING.
IT'S JUST ONE GAME.
GOT TO STAY LOCKED IN.
>> Malika: BEFORE THIS GAME,
YOUR COACH, MONTY WILLIAMS, SAID
THAT EARLIER TODAY, WHEN HE WAS
TRYING TO GO THROUGH THE SCHEME,
HE WAS TOLD, ENOUGH, COACH,
ENOUGH TALKING.
WE JUST WANT TO PLAY.
AND NOW WE SEE YOU WAVING AT
YOUR FAMILY.
WHAT DID IT MEAN TO YOU TO
FINALLY PLAY IN A FINALS GAME?
>> JUST WAVING AT MY FAMILY,
TREVOR ARIZA IS HERE, MY DOG.
CAME HERE TO SUPPORT.
OUR TEAM, COACH SAID IT AT
SHOOTAROUND, SOMETIMES LESS IS
MORE.
YOU KNOW?